[Music]
on this Tuesday night winter blackout
thousands of Canadians without power
face another frigid night
as casualties climb in Buffalo from the
blizzard of this Century
Europe's new Hot Spot what's keeping
Serbia and Kosovo from fighting at least
for now
lies and deception the man elected to
U.S Congress who admits he made up his
credential
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Chris gayles good
evening and thanks for joining us for
many Canadians it has been a holiday
season for the history books as extreme
weather continues to dominate the final
days of 2022 on the west coast the
second of two post-christmas storms is
bringing heavy rain and extremely high
King Tides the storm surge caused some
flooding in downtown Vancouver and the
City closed its iconic Stanley Park sea
wall for safety back East utility crews
are still working to restore power to
thousands of people in Ontario Quebec
and New Brunswick following Fierce
winter storms there Mackenzie gray has
the latest
the lakefront homes in Crystal Beach
Ontario transformed into an apocalyptic
icy scene the mist from the massive
waves coming off Lake Erie forming
immense icicles crippling the community
look at this man residents don't have
power but shockingly damage to these
homes seems to be minimal so I went into
the bottom of my house it's totally dry
which is really quite surprising
Quebec Remains the worst hit by power
outages 35 000 customers without
electricity days after the major storm
passed through we're still hoping to
have uh the vast majority of our clients
reconnected before the end of the day
today but even from Sunny Punta Cana the
impacts are still being felt Susan Hower
luck was supposed to return to Saskatoon
on December 21st but sung Wing has kept
canceling her flights home daughter at
home her very first Christmas this year
it was really tough to hear that and I
kept thinking okay the next day the next
day came along it's the exact same story
sun wing isn't alone and having issues
yesterday 68 of all WestJet flights were
delayed Air Canada was only slightly
better at 62 percent and for Porter 44
percent of flights were late to depart
for those lucky enough to get on a
flight your luggage might not have
accompanied you passengers at Pearson
International in Toronto forced into a
holiday scavenger hunt it's three days
later I'm still trying to find my bag
and as you can see looking over here the
best they could do is
just go look through the bags sift
through the bags see if you can find
yours that's the best they could do even
politicians weren't immune to travel
delays we had a couple things uh flight
cancellation lost luggage uh I'm among
the people that are going back to
Pearson shroud to find my luggage after
two days of cancellations VIA Rail is
back up and running taking passengers to
Montreal Toronto and here to Ottawa it's
a rare win Chris for a difficult travel
season
no doubt Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank
you Mackenzie and the severe weather is
also impacting Canada's blood supply
Canadian Blood Services has an urgent
need for donors with a shortfall of
expected blood and plasma collections
now the storm system that hit Southern
Ontario has taken a catastrophic toll
South of the Border more than 30 people
have died in Buffalo New York as Reggie
cicchini shows us officials call it the
worst weather disaster to hit the area
in a generation
before the storm enters the history
books residents in and around Buffalo
New York must still cope with the
present the blizzard conditions of
course are gone but we're going to be
responding in some ways to this blizzard
for still a number of days Power is
coming back on and most highways are
slowly reopening
though a state of emergency remains in
place and a federal disaster Declaration
was approved on Monday this once in a
lifetime blizzard hit hard and the scars
are still forming going into homes going
into vehicles and too many tragic times
of finding people who did not survive
the experience dozens of people in this
region lost their lives a number of
officials believe will grow
and while the storm's impact is
painfully evident across Western New
York much further south arctic cold has
also wreaked havoc on water systems
through parts of South Carolina and in
Mississippi resulting in boil water
advisories for the second time since
August you get
hundreds of people throughout the city
of Jackson with no water travel also
remains at a crawl most airports except
for Buffalo are open just crowded and
while airlines are slowly coming around
Southwest Airlines is far behind
canceling thousands of flights Monday
and Tuesday due to inundated scheduling
systems we end up with flight Crews and
airplanes that are out of place and not
in the cities that they need to be in
our processes our I.T our infrastructure
just wasn't there to support the
operation and unfortunately our
customers are bearing the Run of it
there will now be a federal review Into
the airline's operating procedures
little Solas to those left behind by a
storm many will try to but few will
likely forget
Reggie takini Global News
we have some breaking news for you now
and Ontario Provincial Police Officer
has been shot and killed and two
suspects arrested it happened during an
altercation in Hagersville Ontario south
of Hamilton this afternoon sources say
the officer was shot after stopping a
vehicle that had been reported missing
police now have a man and a woman in
custody
pressure is growing on Ottawa to change
Canada's criminal code to define
femicide the murder of women because
they're women according to the Canadian
femicide Observatory
173 Canadian women were killed by
violence in 2021 up from the year before
and as nitu Garcia reports critics say
little is being done to stop the
violence
these are the names of murdered women
from across Canada including at least 10
killed by their male partner or
ex-partner in BC there were women in the
community and we don't want them to be
forgotten organizers of this vigil say
the criminal justice system failed to
prevent violent crimes which involved
repeat offenders who were released and
failed to obey conditions of no contact
often little is ever known about these
victims we don't know the name of the
women we do not know who killed them so
we want the chief corner of British
Columbia to release to the public every
time a woman is murdered by her male
partner
in Montreal police are investigating a
possible murder suicide after a man and
woman were found dead in an apartment
building Tuesday Morning police say the
woman's body showed signs of violence
and it appears the man took his own life
we see year after year more women
murdered than previous years Megan
Walker is a member of the London Police
Services Board in Ontario she's leading
their effort to push Ottawa to Define
femicide in the criminal code how many
is enough for people to take notice and
so
um it's just absolutely tragic and and
it needs to change the United Nations
lists at least 15 countries which have
recognized femicide as a distinct
criminal act others consider it a hate
crime but Canada doesn't track
gender-based violence back in Vancouver
it's hoped a new coroner review will
help change that and lead to increased
funding I've written a letter to the
chief coroner seeking a death panel
review which is something that they have
done previously that examines the
domestic homicides within the province
we just want to see real actions and not
empty words these Advocates say change
is needed because for every woman who is
murdered there are thousands more living
in fear need to karcha Global News
Vancouver
Europe on a high alert coming up the new
flare-up between Kosovo and Serbia
a new conflict is brewing between Serbia
and Kosovo in recent weeks barricades
were built inside ethnic Serb areas of
Kosovo Serbia put its Army on high
combat Alert in response Redmond Shannon
reports on the recent events
contributing to the tension
the Serbian Army patrols its border with
Kosovo a border Serbia doesn't formally
recognize on the kosovan's side ethnic
serbs who make up six percent of
kosovo's population set up more
roadblocks as part of the recent
escalation of tensions in Europe's
newest Nation NATO's k-4 peacekeeping
troops say they are investigating the
firing of gunshots on Christmas Day
although no one was hurt
Kosovo declared independence from Serbia
in 2008 it is mostly ethnic Albanian
with pockets of ethnic serbs Serbia does
not recognize its status neither do
Russia or China
Mir the head of the Orthodox Church in
Serbia calls for peace as he meets with
the country's President
Alexander vucic says the west and
kosovan albanians want to see serbs
killed he has again put his Armed Forces
into high combat Readiness that in
response to kosovo's prime minister
saying his government will remove the
barricades unless k-4 troops do so
should the Kosovo authorities decide to
do something like that there is a
question as to whether
um this is going to lead to further
escalations obviously we hope that is
not going to be the scenario tensions
Rose this year over a kosovan proposal
to make ethnic serbs use kosovan car
license plates rather than Serbian
plates 600 kosovan serbs resigned from
kosovo's police force last month even
just the mere presence of of K4
obviously serves as a very strong
deterrence for both sides to escalate
the tensions further ethnic serbs are
pushing for more autonomy some something
kosovo's government says is not on the
table at least for now Redmond Shannon
Global News London
the liar elected to U.S Congress just
ahead plus the impact of new attacks
from Russian forces against Ukraine
[Music]
Russian forces have launched another
major assault on Ukraine near the city
of bakmut flames erupted at this large
Residential Building leaving people
Homeless bakmut was home to about 70
thousand people before the war it's now
mostly a bombed out Ghost Town Russian
President Vladimir Putin claims he's
ready for talks to end the war but
Ukraine and the West believe it's a ploy
to buy time after multiple military
losses
Taiwan is extending mandatory military
service from four months to one year as
tensions grow with China the country is
bolstering its defense in the event of
an attack from Beijing China is ramping
up pressure on Taiwan to assert his
sovereignty claims Taipei which rejects
beijing's claims reported the largest
ever Chinese incursions around the
island yesterday
newly elected U.S congressman George
Santos has admitted he lied about his
qualifications during his successful
campaign for a seat in the House of
Representatives Santos a New York
Republican elected in November confirmed
that some of the key findings of a New
York Times investigation into his
background were correct he acknowledges
he didn't graduate from college and made
misleading claims that he worked for two
high-profile Wall Street firms Santos
says he's still determined to take the
oath of office on January 3rd
gone but not forgotten next remembering
one of Canada's top selling cookbook
authors
top selling Canadian cookbook author
Gene Perry has died at the age of 95.
Perry gained worldwide Fame for her
company's coming cookbook series the
farm girl from Alberta built a major
Publishing Company authoring more than
200 cookbooks the Order of Canada
recipient died Christmas Eve in Edmonton